These lines are both written in the same form, even though we have different
variable names now than we normally do when we talk about slope intercept form.
These equations are both in the same form as y equals m x plus b. We have a
variable on one side, a constant times a variable, and then a constant term
tacked on to the end. This is true for this equation as well. Becasue they are
in slope intercept form, we can just read off their slopes from the equation
directly. They do not have different slopes, they have the same slope. That's
what being parallel means after all. What changed we moved from the old
situation to the new situation with the surplus solution was the g intercept. We
can find that g intercept need equation in the slide where b normally is in
slope intercept form. If I wanted to graph these pretty informally I may little
sketch up here, I would have our first line like this. In the second line,
exactly parallel to it, but just shifted up on the vertical axis. The
information we used to create the second equation then, came from us knowing the
slope that this new line should have, and also one point that it should go
through, 0, 20 which we reflected in the g-intercept part of the equation.